all right I got a chance to check out
the king of first-person shooters
battlefield 3 I get a little early to
say that but you know what it is the
king of first-person shooters you know
why because I played that [ __ ] and that
[ __ ] is awesome the only bummer is the
demo here had the playstation 3 version
looked great but it wasn't a mouse and
it wasn't the keyboard so headshots good
luck on that [ __ ] but still the game was
great it looked great the lighting in
this game is just ridiculous it handled
really well I'm getting this game if you
haven't pre-ordered it pre-order it I
don't even work for a gaming company
that's just the grace of my good hunt
and I'm telling you to pre-order this
[ __ ] because it's awesome this is
actually the line that um I saw a couple
fans in and they let me cut in with them
cut the line down by half I don't know
if that makes me a douche bag or a smart
person but it makes me Jeremy
all right so last but not least star
wars the old republic I just came back
from a presentation on Old Republic they
talked about everything we've always
heard how this thing has like 900 voice
actors on 10,000 named MPC's hundreds of
thousands of lines of dialogue it wasn't
playing at a live forever anyway I'm in
can actually found out that david hayter
AKA solid snake from metal gear solid
he's a voice in the game jennifer hale
she's the voice in the game I heard
Simon templeman during the demo and
that's supposed to me because I love me
some legacy it came the graphics are
really sharpened up i mean the shadows
are sharpened up the game looks a
hundred times better than did last year
last year it looked kind of basic and i
was a little disappointed in that we got
pvp we got like games like some sort of
game remind me of the blitz ball game
it's like a Hut ball or something like
that remind me of bliss ball from Final
Fantasy 10 star wars the old republic
looks like literally the most enormous
MMO that you've ever heard of it's the
largest star wars story hi douche this
game looks better and better every time
and I'm telling you I'm getting this
game I really got nothing negative to
say about it it just looks good if I was
excited last year I am beyond excited
this year
I almost ran into my exit packs who
don't need that [ __ ] ah I got to get it
out there in the universe otherwise I'm
gonna be thinking about it long talking
about over public